de Gaulle l'homme à base documentaire
réalisé par Emmanuel Amara l'homme à
battre pour les États-Unis c'est du
moins vous venez de le voir la thèse
défendue par ce film durant la Seconde
Guerre mondiale tout d'abord puis après
son retour au pouvoir en 1958 ce film a
quoi qu'il en soit de quoi susciter le
débat un débat que nous allons
maintenant avoir sur ce plateau de débat
doc avec nos invités en commençant par
vous
Eric Banca sommes très heureux de
recevoir vous êtes historien et
journaliste et vous avez été conseillé
historique sur ce documentaire
documentaire lui-même inspiré de votre
ouvrage publié aux éditions Perrin
intitulées l'ami américain puis en face
de vous André caspy bienvenue à vous
André Kaspi vous êtes historien
spécialiste de l'histoire des États-Unis
anciens directeur du Centre de Recherche
d'histoire nord-américaine
Eric Banca c'est vrai qu'il suscite
débat ce film c'est pas votre film vous
n'avez pas réalisé vous avez été je l'ai
dit conseiller historique et la thèse
défendue dans c'est finalement les
États-Unis n'ont eu de 16 de vouloir
déstabiliser écartés de Gaulle du
pouvoir alors de cesse pas tout à fait
puisque il y a quand même deux
parenthèses de Gaulle s'entendait plutôt
bien avec eyeshower qui n'était pas un
adversaire et c'est réconcilie avec
Nixon qui n'a côtoyé que quelques mois
mais c'est vrai que pendant toute la
période de Gaulle a posé un problème aux
Américains les Américains avaient un
problème avec de Gaulle alors que de
Gaulle n'avait pas de problème mais que
américains je rappelle que dès l'appel
du 18 juin 40 il fait appel aux
États-Unis quand il parle les forces
immenses qui n'ont pas encore donné et
qui plus tard submergeront l'adversaire
il pense aux Etats-Unis et donc il se
tourne vers eux d’emblée en revanche le
moins qu'on puisse dire et que Roosevelt
étant entouré de gens plutôt favorable à
Vichy n'a pas joué le jeu d'emblée et
que les choses sont mal parti tout de
suite et ne se sont arrangés que
rarement et épisodiquement alors les
Américains avaient un problème avec de
Gaulle et de Gaulle n'en avait pas les
Américains vous êtes d'accord avec ça
pas tout à fait d'abord je crois que le
film montre pour la période de la guerre
une sorte de complot américain
systématique contre de Gaulle mais il
faut bien comprendre comment les choses
se passent en 1940 nous sommes à
quelques années de la fin de la Grande
Guerre Roosevelt était déjà aux affaires
en
1914-1917 il était secrétaire adjoint à
la marine par conséquent ils connaissait
le personnel français il connaissait
Pétain il ne connaissait pas de Gaulle
un inconnu ou presque
non seulement un inconnu mais un général
qui n'avait aucune assise populaire au
fond tout le monde sait que de Gaulle
était pratiquement seul en juin 1940
c'est ce qui fait sa grandeur mais c'est
ce qui fait aussi ça faiblesse vis-à-vis
des Américains pour les Américains la
France c'est une barrière mais une
barrière qui doit être être aussi solide
que possible contre les Allemands or il
se trouve que la France de 1940 a cédé
et que la France de 1940 ça n'est pas la
France de 1917 ça n'est pas la France de
1918 autrement dit ce qu'il reste de
1917-1918 c'est péta et pour Roosevelt
ça n'est pas qu'il est une admiration
sans borne pour Pétain loin de là mais
pour Roosevelt ce qui compte à partir de
1940 d'abord c'est sa réélection
n'oubliez pas que c'est son troisième
mandat auquel il aspire et d'autre part
c'est de préparer son pays à l'entrée en
guerre et l'entrée en guerre des
États-Unis qui se fait en décembre 1941
Pearl Harbour bien sûr est un événement
décisif dans l'histoire de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale autrement dit la France
dans cette affaire joue un rôle mineur
Mineur encore plus lorsqu'il s'agit de
De Gaulle puisque c'est un général que
Roosevelt ne connaît pas il un défi du
pouvoir militaire et en conséquence il
préfère dans un premier temps s'appuyer
sur Pétain n'apporte comment il
considère que la France ne peut plus
tenir un rôle important depuis qu'elle a
subi la défaite de 1940 donc je crois
que c'est cela qu'il faut retenir des
relations entre deux Gaules et
roussevelt au début de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale alors vous parlez de ces
fameuses relations de Gaulle Roosevelt
on va voir un premier extrait du film
c'est justement la rencontre entre les
deux hommes nous sommes au début de
l'année 1943 à Casablanca je reviendrai
après si vous le permettez sur une chose
qui a dites André casi bien entendu la
première rencontre entre Roosevelt et de
Gaulle espace mal puisque lors de sa
rencontre avec Roosevelt les rideaux
bougeaient et que derrière les rideaux
il y avait des agents de l'OSS armé de
mitraillettes Thompson calibre 45 et le
chef des gains de dit le président nous
a dit que c'était un apprenti dictateur
on veut le aucun risque on attend qu'il
essaye d'être enguer le président et on
le transformera en passoire le général
et il avait remarqué et il dira plus
tard il me prenne pour l'assassin de
Lincoln d'ailleurs on vous a vu dans
cette extrait Éric Branca bon les
relations sont pour le moins fraîches à
l'occasion de cette première rencontre
absolument répondre absolument
sur la relation entre les deux hommes
tout à fait exact bien évidemment de
Gaulle n'était pas connu et Pétain avait
l'avantage de l'âge et du passé mais le
passif est très est arrivé très vite
après puisque les la collaboration c'est
instauré et que à partir d'un certain
moment il y avait plus de doute possible
sur l'engagement de la France dans la
collaboration et que lorsque Alger
Roosevelt choisit d'Arlon qui était
ministre de du maréchal Pitt puis le
borationniste collaborationniste qui a
qui a donné les aérodromes de aux
Allemands etc etc qui a dit d'ailleurs
dans un télégramme de 1940 que j'ai
retrouvé à l'ambassadeur Freeman
Matthews nous souhaitons la victoire de
l'Allemagne il le dit deux ans avant
Laval ce qui enverra Laval au plateau
n'exécution donc les États-Unis jouent
d'argent qui joue voilà et dans un
second temps il joue Giraud contre de
Gaulle donc alors après autant André
Casper raison sur le constat de départ
autant après moi je me sépare un peu de
lui parce que ici vous avez choisi des
gens qui l'auraient pu éviter de choisir
il peut être excusé pour Pétain mais les
deux autres c'est quand même et surtout
d'argent attendez
essayez il n'est pas tout à fait exact
de dire que Roosevelt choisit d'argent
il se trouve que Darlan est présent à
Alger au moment du débarquement et ce
n'est pas à vous que j'apprendrai que un
mois et demi plus tard Darlan est
assassiné par conséquent l'épisode de
Darlan est tout à fait temporaire c'est
l'expédie l'expédier en provisoire
c'est-à-dire au fond c'est ce qui est
nécessaire pour assurer la décide de
l'opération militaire là où vous avez
raison c'est que Roosevelt choisit Giro
alors il choisit Giraud pourquoi parce
que au fond il essaye sur Giraud
simplement d'exercer un protectorat
américain le but de Roosevelt pendant
toute cette période c'est
essentiellement de gagner la guerre
c'est ça qu'il faut retenir gagner la
guerre donc ça veut dire que dans
certains cas il y a peut-être des
erreurs qui sont commises il a tort de
choisir Giro parce que Giro quel que
soit ses talents militaires et encore
Giro n'est quand même pas le personnage
qui convient le mieux pour relever la
France d'ailleurs Roosevelt s'en rend
compte assez vite des faiblesses de Giro
tout à fait et c'est même pour cela
d'ailleurs que Roosevelt envoi Jean
Monnet pour essayer de rectifier les
erreurs de gyro alors il y a un passage
sur Jean Monnet que j'ai beaucoup
regretté parce que personnellement il
m'est arrivé de travailler avec Jean
Monnet et j'ai même fait une je mettais
sur Jean Monnet Alger alors lorsque
Roosevelt envoie Jean Monnet à Alger
c'est pour que Giro prononce le discours
du 14 mars 1943 où il réputit Vichy
d'accord mais il est tout à fait exact
que monnaie choisit de Gaulle parce que
plus efficace évidemment néanmoins au
même moment il y a la lettre à
conseiller spécial de Roosevelt Hopkins
dans laquelle
monnaie dit il faut détruire de Gaulle
il faut le détruire cette lettre est
publiée elle est dans les dans les dans
les mémoires de monnaie et surtout dans
la biographie qui a faite de lui
récroucelle c'est pas inventé de ça un
deuxième extrait du documentaire c'est
la fameuse opération en got orchestrée
par les États-Unis concernant et bien
évidemment le débarquement lame got
prévoit des préfets américains mais
aussi une nouvelle monnaie calquée au
format du dollar sur la ils ne sont même
pas inscrits les mots républiques
françaises
pour de Gaulle c'est l'insulte suprême
parce que les attributs de la
souveraineté depuis 20 siècles c'est de
pouvoir battre monnaie si quelqu'un
bamonait à votre place c'est voulu être
subordonné vous n'êtes plus rien alors
François kersody le rappelle c'est à
dire que la monnaie c'est le symbole de
la souveraineté donc les Américains
imaginent cette opération tout
simplement en imaginant de mettre en
place une une administration à sa main
d'une part et d'autre part une monnaie
qui serait j'imagine diriger également
par les Américains
qui a rappelé
cassody n'est pas été mis au courant de
ce débarquement dans les détails en tout
cas les services secrets de la France
libre à Alger et notamment par quelqu'un
dont on parle beaucoup dans le
documentaire qui s'appelle tiro de
rosely qui est devenu d'ailleurs qui est
passé ensuite du bec des services
secrets français directement à la CIA
mais qui a été paradoxalement celui qui
a averti le gouvernement d'Alger de ce
qui se préparait et d'ailleurs que
le nommé tiro de Vosges lui trouvait ça
tout à fait normal ça ne le choquait pas
de quoi n'a pas trouvé ça normal et
comment de Gaulle torpille-t-il en
réalité cette opération c'est une course
de vitesse absolue extraordinaire qui
est un véritable roman puisque au moment
où les Américains débarquent les
commissaires de la République qui ont
été désignés à Londres par Michel Debré
vont surgir du maquis et prendre la
place des préfets de Vichy mais aussi
essayer de le faire quelques minutes
avant que les Américains n'arrivent avec
leur leurs valises de billets alors
c'est une véritable OPA un Orchestra les
États-Unis au moment du débarquement sur
la France peut-être même au-delà sur le
rhum en tout cas sur la France avec
cette opération hangote vous avez tout à
fait raison c'est une c'est une
opération qui est un qualifiable et que
l'on a beaucoup de difficultés à
défendre donc je ne la défendrai pas
mais ce qu'il faut retenir simplement
c'est que pour les Américains ce qui
compte avant tout je l'ai déjà dit
plusieurs fois c'est l'opération
militaire c'est-à-dire il faut réussir
le débarquement il faut assurer la
sécurité des troupes lorsqu'elles seront
sur le territoire français mais il est
évident que il n'est pas dans les
intentions de Roosevelt de remplacer le
front par cette monnaie de papier ou
cette monnaie inventée qui qui devrait
circuler c'est simplement une monnaie
qui est faite pour assurer le
fonctionnement des autorités militaires
c'est à dire on est toujours dans la
même optique et d'ailleurs c'est la
raison pour laquelle Eisenhower n'a pas
protesté là-dessus c'est-à-dire
pour Eisenhower c'est la sécurité on
apprend aussi documentaire que Roosevelt
Tarbes énormément à reconnaître de
Gaulle comme chef du gouvernement
provisoire français à la Libération
c'est ça vous convaincre et c'est pour
une raison très simple c'est à dire
qu'au fond à partir du moment où
Roosevelt comprend qu'il a tort il a
beaucoup de mal à sortir de son
entêtement ça c'est évident il faut pas
il faut pas le nier mais encore une fois
imaginez ce que peut être le souci d'un
président des en 1944 alors il y a
d'abord le souci intérieur parce que
Roosevelt se présente pour la quatrième
fois à un mandat présidentiel mais il y
a surtout le souci de gagner la guerre
c'est ça qui est important c'est pas de
Gaulle de Gaulle au fond à partir du
moment où la France est libérée c'est
l'affaire des Français de régler tout
cela mais pour Roosevelt l'essentiel
c'est de gagner la guerre et en 1944 on
ne peut pas dire que la guerre soit
gagnée elle est gagnée progressivement
c'est ça qui fait la différence donc je
crois que l'optique française est trop
centré sur la France et pas assez sur
les conditions générales du conflit qui
est un conflit mondial et c'est Harry
Truman qui la finira cette guerre dans
le camp américain relation entre Truman
et de Gaulle est-ce que les relations
franco-américaines s'améliorent ou c'est
on est sur la même tonalité existante
pratiquement inexistante ils n'ont pas
le temps parce que exactement Truman
devient président le 14 avril 1945 de
Gaulle quitte le pouvoir en janvier 1946
donc franchement entre temps il y a la
conféria d'abord la bombe atomique
ensuite il y a la conférence de Potsdam
bon autrement dit vous savez faut quand
même pas mettre la France au centre des
débats la France joue un rôle important
surtout entre 1914 et 1918 mais le joue
beaucoup moins en 1945 et c'est grâce à
de Gaulle d'ailleurs qu'elle reprend une
partie de son rang il faut il faut le il
faut lui rendre hommage je le fais très
volontiers mais il ne faut pas le faire
aux dépens des qualités de Roosevelt il
y a une chose
je voudrais vous parler parce que il
donne un sérieux coup de main à de
Gaulle plusieurs fois au moment de la
Libération
Paris et puis Eisenhower permet si on
comprend bien votre documentaire à de
Gaulle de revenir au pouvoir en 58 en
partie il y est favorable en tout cas ce
retour au pouvoir en 58 victoires alors
mais je voudrais finir
à la fin des mémoires de guerre de
gaullehroma Roosevelt et dit si on avait
pu se connaître mieux la guerre est
infinie je pense qu'il aurait accepté
mon point de vue je trouve que
le préciser
ils ont été d'abord son 2 militaires ils
s'entendent bien ils ont des
tempéraments assez proches de Gaulle le
respectent infiniment
et à zedower quand il quand de Gaulle
revient au pouvoir c'est vrai à une peur
bleue des communistes qui à l'époque
font plus de 20% des voix et le désordre
lié aux Affaires algériennes et qui a
présidé au retour de De Gaulle
inquiétait énormément mes américains et
c'est vrai que le la CIA puisque c'est
d'elle qu'on parle beaucoup dans ce
documentaire
a aidé de Gaulle en divisant le groupe
socialiste on demande à une partie du
groupe socialiste le le jeu à 1958 de
voter l'investiture à de Gaulle et c'est
en même temps à ces troublants puisque
on sait tout ça par des archives des
classifiés notamment des témoignages
formidables qui ont été témoignages
oraux qui ont été réunis par le
l'Institut de l'histoire orale du
Département d'État qui a interrogé tous
les témoins de l'époque et il y en a un
qui en 1990 s'appelle Wells Stabler
Wells Stabler était le numéro 2 de
numéro 3 de l'ambassade américaine à
Paris raconte qu'il a évité les gens à
déjeuner et qu'il avait des des hommes
politiques français et qu'il avait des
relations fiduciaires avec certains et
le même qui va demander à la moitié du
groupe socialiste de voter la vessie
dura de Gaulle demandera ensuite à
beaucoup d'autres de voter contre lui et
de s'y opposer alors vous évoquez la CIA
elle est beaucoup évoquée dans ce
documentaire notamment à l'occasion de
la guerre d'Algérie et vous nous dites
des fonds secrets effectivement
financent d'une part dans un premier
temps les indépendantistes autrement dit
le FLN en Algérie puis dans un second
temps l'os autrement dit les partisans
de l'Algérie française tout cela est
vrai entre Kaspi écoutez moi je peux pas
vous dire si c'est vrai bien sûr je vous
avoue franchement je ne suis pas membre
de la CIA mais ce que je sais c'est que
ça ressemble un peu vous savez à ce que
diffuse actuellement une sorte de
plateforme qui s'appelle qnens
c'est-à-dire il y a des complots partout
alors l'histoire se résume à une sorte
de série de complots moi je ne crois pas
je ne crois pas que les complots
l'emportent dans l'histoire je pense que
il peut y avoir des complots bien
entendu mais dans l'ensemble il y a des
intérêts de la part des puissances la
puissance américaine n'a pas intérêt en
1958 à ce que la France se délite et
passe aux communistes puisque en effet
comme on vient de le rappeler les
communistes font entre 20 et 25% des
voix ce qui est énorme quand on
réfléchit bien il n'y a aucun parti
aujourd'hui
qui puisse se vanter d'avoir une même
influence donc ça veut dire que la
France est menacée et en ce sens pour
les Américains ce serait quand même un
des piliers de l'Alliance atlantique qui
s'effondrerait si la France passait
entre les mains des communistes d'où
évidemment l'intérêt d'Eisenhower a
soutenir le général de Gaulle mais je
précise que lorsque Eisenhower quitte le
pouvoir est un nouveau président prend
la tête des États-Unis c'est-à-dire John
def Kennedy en janvier 1961 Kennedy est
reçu à bras ouverts par De Gaulle en
avril et mai
1961 et rappelez-vous peut-être vous
pouvez pas vous rappeler vous n'étiez
pas né mais en 1961 lorsque Jacqueline
Kennedy traverse la place de la Concorde
la voiture ne peut plus avancer
tellement l'enthousiasme est fort donc
il y a vraiment là une sorte d'unité
franco-américaine alors vous allez tout
de même assez loin dans ce documentaire
sur le rôle des services secrets
américains ah oui tout
officiellement répertoriés il y en a eu
beaucoup plus un des tentatives mais
quatre au moins 4 officiellement
répertoriés dont trois attribuent à l'os
et là vous nous dites dans ce
documentaire l'os est en grande partie
financée à les services secrets donc ils
ont réellement voulu abattre un moment
j'ai vu des notes du conseil de cabinet
de 1961 1962 où les preuves étaient
apportées en main propre Michel Debré
c'est un fait c'est un fait des services
secrets de Suisse sont observés un
ballet qui se jouait à Alger en 1962 ou
une France de l'os était réfugiée au
consulat américain
bon ça c'est
l'intérêt de l'os l'os voulait arrêter
pardon excusez-moi des États-Unis les
Américains pensent c'est possible c'est
ça se passe exactement en juin juillet
1962 tout de suite après les accords
d'Évian et tout de suite avant la
dépendance
collective il voulait réconcilier une
phrase réformes du FLN avec une
frange réformiste de l'Ouest si tentait
que ça a été exister bon et donc il y
avait
il y a eu des pour parler qui ont
évidemment raté mais ils en ont été les
les maîtres d'oeuvre ils ont noté les
maîtres d'oeuvre donc ils sont allés
très loin alors reste à savoir si ces
tentatives de la part des services
secrets américains étaient à
l'initiative des services secrets ou à
l'initiative du gouvernement américain
alors politique comme vous le savez
comme vous le savez les services secrets
américains ont très souvent agi de leur
propre initiative sans avoir forcément
je suis 100% d'accord avec André Kaspi
il y a même des télégrammes très
intéressants de Kennedy à de Gaulle où
il demande de faire la lumière
sur le rôle qu'on peut avoir les
services mais ça correspond assez bien
la chronologie
d'ailleurs vous savez ça mieux que moi
mais les rapports entre Kennedy et de
Gaulle n'était pas si mauvais et même je
crois qu'ils ont même après l'affaire
des fusées après l'affaire de Berlin et
après l'affaire des fusées les rapports
se sont améliorés constamment parce que
de Gaulle a été totalement exemplaire il
a été le premier à dire qu'il était du
côté des Américains à ce moment-là le
moins qu'on puisse dire et qui n'a pas
été payé de retour après avec le
successeur de climatique
Johnson qui est dédié était un peu agacé
par l'attitude de Gaulle parce que de
Gaulle le prenait sous sa protection
c'est-à-dire qu'au fond de Gaulle disait
moi je sais j'ai de l'expérience vous
vous êtes un peu jeune vous arrivez aux
affaires donc vous en savez moins que
moi mais cela dit sur le fond vous avez
tout à fait raison il y a des liens je
ne dis pas étroit mais en tout cas des
liens raisonnablement satisfaisants
entre de Gaulle et Kennedy incontestable
ment il dit avec Nixon la fin parce que
là ça a été vraiment une idée très
courte c'est-à-dire que là où les choses
dégénèrent c'est à partir du moment où
il y a une application de plus en plus
grande des États-Unis dans la guerre du
Vietnam bien sûr mais ça c'est
Kennedy est assassiné déjà c'est à dire
qu'au fond c'est après novembre 1963 et
les relations vont à nouveau ce tendre
pour le moins avec lindton Johnson
successeur bien sûr de John Fitzgerald
Kennedy et puis cette annonce choque en
1966 dernière extrait de notre
documentaire
il y avait un sujet sur lequel le
général de Gaulle ne voulait pas
transiger c'est qu'il est sur son
territoire des armes nucléaires
américaines qui auraient été déclenchée
par les Américains ça c'était hors de
question on garde beaucoup de contacts
avec l'OTAN on n'est pas rompa
définitivement tous azimuts avec le
temps mais on dit allez vous installer
ailleurs parce que l'OTAN est installé
en France il y avait des bases encore en
France la prière il y a des bases
américaines elles ont pululé sur tout le
territoire français le rôle a été très
ferme je quitte l'organisation militaire
de l'Alliance atlantique parce qu'elle
est aux mains des Américains je refuse
l'armée européenne parce que c'est
mettre l'armée française ou le
commandement américain je vais pas
accepter
l'organisation militaire de l'Alliance
atlantique qui consiste là à décider à
plainte de la France 7 mars 1966 de
Gaulle donc décide d'annoncer qu'il
quitte en tout cas avec la France quitte
le commandement intégré de l'OTAN la
France reste membre de l'OTAN néanmoins
et d'autre part elle décide de fermer
purement et simplement les bases
américaines qui étaient sur le
territoire français là on a un moment
d'extrême tension et c'est là que les
Américains laissent planer le soupçon
selon lequel de Gaulle serait prêt à
trahir le camp occidental au profit du
qu'on soviétique absolument alors la
question que la rupture c'est très bien
n'a pas été total puisque
les moyennes communication sont restées
les oléoducs sont restés qui qui
alimentaient les les troupes américaines
basées en Allemagne et même la
couverture aérienne a été assurée donc
on n'a pas on a on a fermé les bases de
l'OTAN on n'a pas rompu absolument donc
nous sommes restés dans le cadre de
l'alliance atlantique bande de
l'Alliance atlantique et là aussi les
services secrets américains jouent un
rôle qu'on pourrait qualifier assez
pervers en laissant planer
bien sûr alors ça c'est c'est l'affaire
du fameux film d'Hitchcock les taux qui
est tiré des mémoires de tiro de vos
olives dont je parlais tout à l'heure et
qui laisse planer le doute sur
l'existence d'une cellule
soviétophile à l'Élysée et tout part des
confessions entre guillemets d'un
déflecteur soviétique qui s'appelait
Golite sin qui est passé aux États-Unis
en 1960 et qui a promis aux Américains
des révélations alors il a effectivement
dénoncé un espion soviétique qui était
Georges pack qui travaillait le temps il
travaille pas à l'Elysée il travaille à
l'OTAN Georges pack il donnait des plans
aux Soviétiques ça c'est certain mais il
promet aussi d'autres noms qui ne donne
jamais et
le psychiatre de la CIA qui s'applique
anger à longtemps
interroger le nommé golikin et a dit au
numéro 2 de la CIA de James angolton il
faut pas continuer à écouter ce que dit
ce personnage c'est un grave paranoïaque
le fait que la France décide de quitter
l'OTAN sous l'égide de De Gaulle ça a
été un choc est-ce que Lindon Johnson a
cru un instant que la France
allait bel et bien trahir le camp
occidental au profit du consoviétique je
pense que Lindon Johnson ne devait pas
être très préoccupé par ce qui se
passait en France parce que autant
Roosevelt songeait avant tout à gagner
la guerre et il avait parfaitement
raison autant Lindon Johnson était
complètement engoncé
englué dans la guerre du Vietnam c'est
son souci primordial et non seulement la
guerre du Vietnam mais entre 1965 et
1967 la société américaine éclate de
toutes parts il y a des manifestations
dans des centaines de villes ce que l'on
voit aujourd'hui n'est rien par rapport
à ce qui existait dans les années 60
donc Johnson n'est pas fait pour la
grande politique internationale il est
fait avant tout pour régler des
problèmes même intérieur c'est à dire la
réaction à l'encontre de la guerre du
Vietnam et comment arrêter cette espèce
de déluge de manifestation qui
encombrent les États-Unis mais d'un
autre côté il faut dire que la décision
de Gaulle est brutale ça veut dire quand
même que il y a une rupture entre les
États-Unis et la France et une rupture
qu'il est difficile d'accepter du point
de vue américain même si du point de vue
français on peut à la rigueur la
comprendre mais ça veut dire que pour
les Américains c'est une sorte de
trahison de la confiance que l'on
pouvait avoir dans un pays un pays qui
joue un rôle important d'autant plus
important ce pays que le général de
Gaulle est à sa tête et qu'en somme la
France relève la tête ça n'est plus
simplement la France a battu de 1940
c'est pas la France qu'on va lescendre
de 1945 c'est une France qui désormais
tient les rênes de son avenir et
souhaite de reprendre sa place dans le
monde et les symbole d'ailleurs de de
cette stratégie gaulliste c'est la
bombasse
de la sortie de l'OTAN c'est que la
bombe atomique le fait que la France
rejoint un rôle sur l'international
était incompatible avec le maintien dans
une organisation où on n'avait pas le
dernier mot c'était pas possible mais
simplement je serai d'accord nous
serions d'accord tous les deux
d'ailleurs il y a aussi des raisons que
nous soyons désaccord mais je serai tout
à fait d'accord avec vous si vous ne
mettiez pas systématiquement en avant
les les aberrations les projets les
hypothèses des services spéciaux parce
que toute l'histoire des relations entre
les États ne repose pas uniquement sur
les services spéciaux je suis
complètement d'accord avec vous il
n'empêche qu'il y a eu des manipulation
qui ont été attestées par les Américains
eux-mêmes dans leur document
déclassifiés ils ne sont nulle part
inventé et j'ai été très prudent tout à
l'heure et je de maintien avec je suis
sûr qu'il était pour rien en tout cas
pas pour grand chose dans tout ça je
pense au contraire que Johnson
l'encouragait parce que engelton le
numéro 2 de la CIA qui est resté pendant
près de 13 ans parce que les directeurs
ont beaucoup valsé il y avait un type
qui s'appelle engleton et qui était
vraiment le directeur opérationnel la
CIA et il était très proche de Johnson
lui très proche et puis les relations
vont se normaliser avec vous l'avez dit
Richard Nixon sur un laps de temps très
court puisque Nixon arrive au pouvoir au
moment où de Gaulle s'en va on arrive en
janvier le 20 janvier
mais c'est plus qu'une normalisation
c'est une il y a les bourses d'un
changement de pied des Américains c'est
à dire que Nixon et l'héritier
d'Eisenhower absolument parce qu'une
action était le vice-président
Eisenhower donc il saute Nixon par
dessus la parenthèse démocrate les
républicains sont favorables à de Gaulle
beaucoup plus que les démocrates et ça
sera le mot de la fin vraiment un grand
grand merci à tous les deux d'avoir
participé à ce débat doc aujourd'hui
consacré vous l'avez compris aux
relations entre de Gaulle et les
États-Unis vos réactions ça sera sur
hashtag des Badoc bien sûr sur Twitter
rendez-vous à tous et à toutes pour un
prochain débat doc même place même heure
avec son documentaire et son débat à
bientôt
[Musique]